This morning, I was headed out the door
and my wife saw me and she said,
"Oh, you look fancy today."
And I didn't know what
she was talking about
and I looked in the mirror and I realized
that I wore a shirt with
buttons, a button up shirt.
That passes for fancy
Yeah.
in this COVID
world we're in now.
I always just throw on a T-shirt.
Right.
And then some sort of jean
jacket and I do the show,
this morning I put on
a shirt that's completely
normal, you know?
Right.
And it looks like I'm
headed out the door to my wedding.
It's, it's also a lot of work,
all those buttons,
that shows a lot of
ambition so kudos to you.
Thank you.
Yeah.
It's actually just velcro.
Oh, right.
Yeah.
The buttons are just here and then it just
Right, right.
flips down and I can rip this off
and there's no back to this,
it's just a bare back.
I mean, your wife found it fancy,
if that's really--
She didn't see the back,
if she had seen the back, she
would have been horrified.
Yeah, she would have been,
it probably have been like
you got to get that spot looked at.
Yeah.
My wife hasn't seen my
naked torso in eight years.
Well, you got to get better lighting.
She said my skin looks like SPAM
that started to go bad.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, didn't you used to
help out in the health class
by showing the circulatory system
by just standing there with a shirt off?
I get paid a lot of money,
I got $40 a class.
Nice.
They give you a cookie
and watch it pass through
your digestive tract.
Yup.
It's good work, if you can get it.